welcome to my trip to vlog count to you
in three parts my voice went really high
part the first physics my finals papers
are now just two weeks away and so
pretty much all my time surgeon spent
revising this week amongst other things
I'm looking at the park integral
formulation of quantum field theory some
stratospheric chemistry radiation
management in the atmosphere and it
feels like all the physics ever because
I've been working so lon Frank it's
getting quite hard to not be bored in
the library but this is really easier by
the addition of some friends so I was
joining some Peters library by some
friends from the physics society on the
right-hand side we actually have Frank
who's from Mansfield collagen is going
to be next to use physics aside from
president
now the magic mr. Peters are banded
together to form a study group and we
are able to book out rooms in college as
college members and we've been working
out different rooms every evening to
just get out of the library it's really
nice to know that you're not going
through all this exam stress alone also
in kind of physics news I went to new
college level form all over there friend
of mine who's gonna be doing a d4 with
me next year goes there and their halls
being refurbished at the moment so they
actually have their four modules in a
marquee on their cord which was kind of
weird but anyway I had this this and
this part two rowing so on Saturday I
managed to get out of the library for a
couple of hours and slip down to the
river now rowing is kind of famously a
really big sport in Oxford there are
three reactors over the course of the
year and some rates is the one that
happens in Trinity 10 which was the one
that I was at on Saturday
it runs on Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday and it's a huge deal
last year I think 15,000 people lined
the bank to the river so each College
often has its own boathouse or chairs
about and those are rampant with
supporters from the college you'll get
people who aren't rows just coming down
to support their teams X Row is coming
down and watching even some Peters
master Mark Danzer came down so the way
the Sun rates works is a bumped style of
racing this means that instead of having
to Cruise side by side like you would
say in the boat race on the Thames you
have lots of cruise it's ten per
division or one after the other in a
line and nigeria's that when the
starting cannon is fired everybody tries
to crash into you basically the boat in
front of them and doing that is called a
bump and when you bump someone you
leapfrog them in the standings in the
division so you go up on they go down
and when a bump happens in some rates
both the crew which has bumped so has
hit the back in front of them and the
boat that they hit then drops out of the
racing line allows the rest of the race
to continue so Peters main men's boat is
in the second division and we had a
really strong crew this year I try to
keep up um somewhat successfully people
don't realize how fast rowing motor and
you can probably see in this shot just
how close everything was there was
probably two or three feet between each
of the boats
part three thrashing so physics is a
subject which starts its exams really
dating youngest returned most people
start at least two or three weeks before
we do the first subject start overall
was English which means that English was
first subject finish which is what
happened earlier this week as I mention
in one of my previous videos you take
your exams in the examination schools
and when you finished your last exam you
get to walk out via the finalists exit
the finalists exit leads on to Merson
Street which on days when people had
their final exams it's absolutely
lined with friends of people that have
been sitting their exams
English is quite a big subjects though
absolutely loads of people there as you
can see the street was completely packed
and we I was there with a bunch of other
friends to celebrate with those English
students from some Peters who is you
might go tell or rather happy following
the celebration of Martin Street however
but we then come to an option tradition
called thrashing thrashing is the action
of to varying extents I suppose
degrading the person your friend who has
just sat that final exam and so in
theory is having a happiest day of life
here we can see a typical trashing it
starts with people being genuinely happy
that their friend has finished their
exams and then in this case there was
milk water coffee and I think chocolate
sauce and whipped cream this is actually
quite a light thrashing the most extreme
one I've seen was a guy who was tied to
a clothes rack and then thrown in the
river face up you know he was fine after
the thrashing it's also kind of
traditional to jump into the river
running from christchurch meadow
although in some cases people don't like
to hold up the do the job done that's
encouraging
thank you for your suggestions for the
collaboration video with Jamie
if you don't know until come up please
check out the previous vlog or if you
don't know Jamie's check out his vlogs
and your question for this week is based
on my study group so there's a guy I
work with good Dan who you might
remember from I end life video whose mum
in one of the loveliest things I think
I've ever heard sends a motivational
quotes every day to keep him going
through his study and I was thinking
that maybe you guys could leave the most
motivational quote or idea or thought
you ever had or come across in the
comment section and then all of us who
are going through exams at the moment
can sort of feed off that motivation and
we can get down to it together leave
your motivational quotes in the comments
below
Jamie I will see you on Thursday I will
see you guys in a week's time
I just I'll stop cooling so wait what